luego del estallido Social ocurrido en
Chile en 2019 la organización amnistía
internacional remarcó el deficiente
trabajo de la justicia para condenar los
abusos policiales según publicó en su
informe sólo 22 de los 10.936
expedientes sobre las violaciones de
derechos humanos han tenido una
resolución hubo algunos casos de
homicidios
hubo casos de golpiza muy brutales
personas con lesiones oculares
cientos de personas sobre todo niñas
adolescentes que denunciaron haber sido
desnudadas en unidades policiales
amnistía también remarcó que los
procesos de peritaje de 4.402 casos se
han extendido hasta por dos años después
del ataque y que el gobierno no ha
efectuado las reparaciones necesarias
para las víctimas estos datos que
mostrarían que el panorama general es de
mucha impunidad Por cierto son graves y
muestran que el estado de chile ha
estado incumpli sus obligaciones
internacionales esto ya ha pasado más de
un año desde el inicio del gobierno del
presidente borich tres año y medio desde
el inicio del estallido social y todavía
estamos a la espera de
unas políticas integrales de reparación
el reporte también detalla otras fallas
en la atención a Los afectados como el
tratamiento psicológico y la falta de
atención a las personas que no reciben
en Santiago
en contrapartida el congreso promulgó
recientemente una ley que da mayores
facultades a la policía para utilizar
armas de fuego